d-181 was used to being picked as a test
subject for the various dangerous and
downright terrifying experiments and lab
work the scp foundation had him perform
at secure facility site 32. he'd been
working for the organization for nearly
five years and he considered every day
he was alive a blessing and you would
too if you were a d-class personnel
while no one's too sure on the exact
methods the scp foundation uses to
recruit its d-class personnel
there are a few prevalent rumors most of
which you've surely heard before death
row prisoners taken into custody by the
foundation to be unwilling lab rats
ordinary people that society wouldn't
miss that were kidnapped off the streets
or sometimes just volunteers though
we're not sure who in their right mind
would willingly volunteer for one of the
most degrading dangerous positions in
the entire foundation the truth about
d-class is that every site does it
differently and the foundation is well
aware of the controversy among its
personnel that comes with recruiting and
using d-class personnel heck some sites
don't even have d-class citing their use
as inhumane but at site 32 things were
ordinary and d 181 was one of the many
d-class personnel drafted into the
foundation via the united states prison
system day in and day out d-181 would
have to perform tests and experiments
most of which he knew next to nothing
about thankfully for him d-181 had two
benefits that made his stay at site 32 a
little easier first there was the fact
that site 32 was a low priority facility
it was located far away from any major
population centers and overall lacked
the expensive funding some of the larger
sites had the anomalies contained there
were still pretty dangerous but due to
the lack of available funding most of
what the foundation was able to afford
at site 32 was regulated to safe and
euclid-class objects now as we all know
object class has nothing to do with
danger levels and instead is based on
the difficulty the foundation has
containing a certain object more than
anything else so when a site such as
site 32 is underfunded due to being less
of a priority to the larger organization
they're typically only going to be
containing the bare minimum in terms of
expenses that means less expensive
containment and less elaborate objects
for d181 to work with it wasn't a
guarantee of safety as nothing ever is
in the scp foundation but it was at
least beneficial to have an
understanding of what's going on in the
various experiments d-181 had to perform
throughout the day the second thing
d-181 appreciated about site-32 was a
little less conventional the entire
facility was staffed by women with the
exception of male personnel being used
for testing purposes the reason for this
is due to a very specific detail about
today's anomaly which we'll get back to
but it was something that d181 never
took for granted of course d-181 was an
absolute buffoon when it came to dating
and relations between testing subjects
and researchers were discouraged and in
some cases forbidden however he never
gave up hopes that he might be able to
now find a girlfriend while living in a
building that was less than one percent
male in population it is important that
we state that d 181 was always
respectful to women and never stepped
out of line which as far as d-classes go
makes him top-tier boyfriend material
maybe there's hope for him someday so
long as he survives the deadly daily
grind of being on the lowest rung of the
foundation while these two things kept
d-181 as happy as someone could be while
essentially being enslaved to the
foundation there was a lot to be unhappy
about in his position first there was
the general danger that came with
testing with anomalies every day where
anything and everything could go wrong
and your safety was never guaranteed
then there were the dreams most of the
time d181's waking state felt like a
dream so that meant the images his brain
showed him at night were extra weird the
horrors and oddities that d-181
witnessed during the day always came
back to haunt him at night whether it
was a stack of talking bowling balls
attacking him in the grocery store or a
teacup that made his skin invert itself
every time he drank it the scp objects
d-181 worked with always cropped up in
his dreams at night and they always
seemed to be worse d181 asked the other
d-class personnel stationed at the site
if they had strange dreams too and most
of them agreed that they experienced
them as well apparently working for the
foundation fired up the imagination in
an extra special way that seeped into
night time when d-181 would ideally be
receiving some well-deserved sleep from
the strangeness of the day but one dream
was bothering d181 significantly more
than usual it was a recurring one
happening again and again every few
nights the same series of events playing
out over and over again the strangest
part about it was that it didn't feel
like a dream at all d-181 would be
laying in his bunk inside site-32's
d-class barracks desperately trying to
fall asleep eventually he would but he
wouldn't realize it d181 would feel like
he was asleep but he could still see the
barracks around him except he couldn't
move at all d181 was experiencing a form
of sleep paralysis a phenomenon during
falling asleep or waking up where a
person is unable to move or speak
hallucinations during sleep paralysis
are common but the whole experience
typically only lasts a few minutes for
d181 it lasted a lot longer and he was
aware the entire time so d-181 would be
laying down in his bunk trying to fall
asleep when he would suddenly become
unable to move then from across the room
he'd see the door to the barracks open
d-181 knew that the barracks were only
accessible to the upper ranking
personnel and they never came around
first d-181 saw a large cylinder move
itself slightly into the room then the
figure it was attached to waddled its
way through the door a giant fabric doll
so big that it could barely fit itself
into the door if d-181 could scream he
would he recognized the figure as an
instance of
[Music]
scp-2386 one of the anomalies he was
working on the doll walks slow and heavy
trying to not collapse over its own
weight it was made of pink fabric with
its face stitched together with thread
forming a sly smile and two buttons for
eyes it was terrifying what was even
worse were the two pairs of wings on the
doll's back like the kinds you'd see on
a butterfly or a moth the brilliant
patterns look like they were made of
cloth sewn to a pair of ordinary insect
wings and completing the doll's
patchwork appearance the insect doll
combination stumbled towards d-181
moving across the barracks slowly and
nearly falling over several times the
creeping terror of the doll's slow
advance only made d181 try to move more
but he couldn't he was completely
paralyzed and subject to whatever the
doll was about to do to him eventually
the doll made it close to d181's bunk
standing over the bed and staring at
d-181 with its lifeless button-eyed face
it just stood there staring d-181 was
sweating with tears in his eyes he tried
to scream again but nothing came out and
then to make matters worse the barracks
door opened again and what made its way
through shook d-181 to his very core it
was another doll even bigger than the
other one and behind it was another doll
and then another four dolls in total
made their way into the room and
stumbled over to d-181's bed they
continued to stare crowding around the
sleeping d-class like he was a
television set and their favorite show
was about to begin
just when d-181 thought it couldn't get
any worse the dolls extended their
stubby felted hands over his face all
four of them moving in unison and then
they stopped and d181 heard their voices
well not their voices exactly but voices
nonetheless high-pitched barely human
childish voices started whispering to
him they weren't coming from the dolls
but they could talk d-181 was positive
this is what they'd sound like
[Applause]
all of these seemingly innocuous phrases
were things said to d181 while he was
surrounded by the giant dolls on paper
they sound encouraging but the context
of the situation and the way they were
said made them anything but and this
would continue for what seemed like
hours with the dolls crowding d181 and
speaking to him in his paralyzed state
shouting the most deceptively kind
things possible over and over again all
while d181 was aware the entire time but
before he would wake from this awful
dream one of the instances would lift
their stubby hand forward directly
hovering over d-181's arm and the doll's
appendage would caress him squeezing and
playing with his arm like it were a toy
by morning when d181 awoke from his
dream he felt like he was never asleep
in the first place and that he could
remember every agonizing second of the
past night's experience this would
continue almost every other night as
soon as d181 would fall asleep the doll
dream would occur again as soon as he
woke up he feel like he got next to no
sleep the night before it was draining
him and inhibiting d181 from performing
his duties accordingly one day during
testing d-181 fell asleep in the middle
of an experiment and dropped an
important component to the object he was
working with which nearly set the entire
facility on fire after that d181 knew
that something had to change d181
recognized the dolls they were instances
of scp-2386
which he had worked with previously in
fact it was the experiments with
scp-2386 that injured d-181 on his right
arm causing an infectious spot to crop
up what caused this and what exactly is
scp-2386
we'll get to all of that soon enough but
we need to focus on the dreams it was
three weeks into the dreams three weeks
since d181 was injured during testing
and three weeks since d181 had a good
night's sleep he met with dr shaw the
head researcher in charge of
scp-2386 experimentation and someone who
worked with d-181 many times dr shawn
d-181 sat down and prepared an interview
she began good morning d181 you say
you've been having recurring dreams
d-181 shuffled in his seat a bit yeah hi
doc ever since i got this thing it
wasn't that bad at first d-181 of course
was talking about the red spot on his
arm shaw asked him to explain the dreams
and d181 did he explained how he would
be in his bunk feeling almost awake but
not quite when giant versions of
scp-2386 would make their way into the
room they'd gather around his bed and
stare at him shouting things and
caressing his infected spot dr shaw
listened intently d-181 was clearly
shaken up from relaying the experience
to another person he continued barely
able to hold himself together you see
something had changed the night before
d181 spoke to dr shaw for the first time
the dream was altered
actually last night they did something
different another one came in it had
something with it looked like a baby one
it was all wrapped up in this white
cloth they said something about wanting
to show me what i was working towards
they pulled back the cloth over its head
and it was a bug's head look me right
the heck up a baby with a bug's head was
definitely strange imagery but dr shaw
was unsure what it all could mean she
knew
scp-2386 were insect-like and with the
way d-181's infection was looking her
brain began concocting a strange but
potentially true theory one that wasn't
looking good for d181
but before we get into that let's talk
about what
scp-2386 really is they're known among
foundation personnel at site32 as pink
ladies and they are a diminutive species
that outwardly resembles patchwork dolls
made of traditional fabric think that
creepy raggedy ann doll your grandmother
has but 10 times more degraded a whole
lot more pink and straight up insectoid
in nature they're not as big as the ones
in d181 screen but they're actually as
scary with stitched on faces and a pair
of moth wings on their backs in fact the
actual
scp-2386 instances range from only seven
to nine centimeters tall autopsies on
dead instances of scp-2386
showed resemblances to human botflies
and silkworms two species of insects
that are absolutely nasty it is
terrifying to imagine something so
outwardly cuddly could look so downright
ugly on the inside but that's what
scp-2386
are but don't try hugging them either
their cotton fiber exoskeleton is as
durable as it is gross and they're not
the kind of cuddly doll you'd want to
take to bed at night in the wild
scp-2386 are found in hives resembling
similarly patterned seat cushions big
mounds of cloth hose to tons of these
tiny terrors with the biggest hive the
foundation ever came across being the
size of a large sofa these hives are
commonly found near suburban
environments and sometimes even inside
occupied housing imagine coming home to
find a brand new sofa inside your house
and then realizing that it's actually
home to thousands of
scp-2386 instances when scp-2386 leaves
their colonies it is primarily to feed
on smaller insects and seek out hosts
for reproductive purposes despite their
cute but gross appearances
scp-2386 become hostile if approached by
males of any species and will target
them accordingly that's why site 32 only
employs male personnel for testing
purposes as soon as they're within range
of a male subject
scp-2386 will outstretch one of its
appendages and extend a pair of
scissor-like claws from it before
swarming the male this is what happened
to d181 which resulted in the red
infected spot on his arm conversely
female subjects in the presence of
scp-2386 are treated entirely
differently with the instances caring
for them presenting them with small
gifts and attempting to play with them
during the spring and summer seasons
scp-2386 will enter their mating season
and cease their hostilities towards
males instead they'll treat them with
the same level of kindness they do with
females but this kindness is just a
front when given the opportunity
scp-2386 will slice a small incision
into the male's subject and pump them
full of about 30 to 65 eggs underneath
their skin within 24 hours the incised
area will resemble pattern cloth and
genetic tests reveal it to be composed
of the same material as
scp-2386's hives in the weeks that
follow this area will spread across the
subject's body and eventually it will
open to reveal fully grown adult
instances of scp-2386
who burst from the patchwork's skin dr
shaw recognized that this is what was
happening to d181 and immediately got
him to site32's medical ward d-181 was
strapped down to the table and tried not
to freak out over what he knew was about
to happen the dreams were acting as a
warning and
scp-2386 was clearly looking forward to
having d-181 bear the next generation of
insect dolls thankfully dr shaw caught
the infection before the patchwork skin
was able to fully take root meaning that
the eggs underneath d181 skin were
premature thankfully there was still
time surgery was carried out immediately
and the doctors weren't surprised to
discover a colony of premature
scp-2386 eggs underneath d181's arm they
were removed from the body and thrown
into storage for further research
purposes
d-181 after waking up from the surgery
thanked dr shaw at least now he wouldn't
have to deal with those horrible dreams
and the stinging swollen sensation
underneath his arm unfortunately he was
still a d-class personnel working for
the foundation and would have many more
intense experiences after this one but
d-181's gratefulness would soon subside
within a few hours d181 began to ask dr
shaw if he could see
scp-2386's enclosure he spent the past
few weeks absolutely terrified of the
species but for whatever reason he felt
like he had unfinished business with the
anomalies he wanted to see them again dr
shah became suspicious and
understandably denied d181 entrance from
the enclosure but this wasn't enough
d-181 became violent and tried to force
himself into the containment chamber he
needed to see them he couldn't explain
why but he felt incomplete eventually
d-181 was subdued and returned to his
quarters but his symptoms continued
throughout the weeks he was depressed
and frequently made reference to
scp-2386
as being lost or unrightfully taken away
from him to dr shaw what was happening
was clear d-181 had been affected
mentally upon receiving the scp-2386
eggs this was a safety mechanism induced
by the anomaly in case of birthing
complications so d-181 would feel
compelled to receive another batch of
eggs into his body if the first batch
was lost or damaged it was disgusting
and shaw was positive it would subside
after a few more weeks but what kept her
up at night wasn't the same dreams d-181
had or the terror of scp-2386
it was the image of d-181 scared and out
of his mind clawing that containment
chamber door begging to be used as a
host for
scp-2386's next batch of eggs now go
check out
scp-3004 insect god immago and scp-439
bone hive for more anomalous
scp-explained videos that will bug you
out